alors merci merci invitation ce contrat
ici aujourd'hui ces mêmes forces
commerciales et un bail
il ya des trucs qui serait qu'on peut
parler de sujets qui seraient semble un
peu l'exception des secteurs différents
oui charlie seulement les quelques jours
fait à mon apport à toi bourse on
travaille avec de la dngc qui pendant
les animateurs matin j'ai le matériel
quotidien pour sa musique poser des
questions aux recherches
ce que j'aimerais notre faveur nous
jouons plus me le montrer que ce forum
internet génétique qui ne nous fait une
vie qui fait qu'on ait aujourd'hui
pourrait être utilisé à bon escient pour
l'annexion en appel à la haute
définition
si tu m'as francis heude où il joue
comme ça c'est des conditions souvent
d'accord alors à la finale au sujet de
cette fameuse médecine la côte
définition
revenons dans un quartier votre rendez
vous elle bienvenue chez votre médecin
c'est ce qu'on demande aujourd'hui à la
population de port est exagéré système
c'est après 55 m2 world jean médecin de
famille à tous les deux quelle femme
médecin de famille pour eux dit de lui
et votre santé en fait poser un
diagnostic sur votre état médical
il va simplement se baser sur des
enfants
cette posture poser des questions sur
vos études devine ce que vous mangez ce
que vous faire puisque vous êtes actif
bien sûr aussi se baser sur les
paramètres biochimiques grande et des
prises de sang et paramètres physiques
votre poids votre engin déception en
curieusement malgré ce plongeon de notre
société
on est encore là bas que le médecin doit
encore gérer votre diagnostic avec
relativement peu de données à fait
compétence que l'appel a plutôt affaire
des religions est ce que il sera
possible de voir un jour où l'ont
finalement qu'à la médecine moderne
puisse passer en haute résolution et un
mineur les pin's des dix dernières
années puis géré discipline ce soit en
chimie et en physique en ingénierie en
médecine il s'est développé une nouvelle
technologie wasquehal mais on peut
imaginer de l'imagerie médicale au
niveau on peut imaginer croire chercher
l'information ou de nuire au niveau
essentiellement des canicules de la
villa des herbes les protéines on te
regarde et bussigny facteurs
environnementaux grande échelle qui j'ai
une population est un humain en
particulier on peut même commencer à
regarder quels sont les facteurs
physiques psychologiques qui peuvent
influencer les autres patients dont
qualité cette médecine à la haute
définition vise à capturer la diversité
du patient en fournissant le maximum
d'informations à venir dans quelques
instants
donc imaginez votre personne ici
où est ce qu'il
dc d'avoir développé des technologies
moi je compagnie maximiser d'information
qui représente l'état du patient
aujourd'hui bien sûr parce qu'elle
permettait à des poussées sur une audi
tt terminal qui contrôle le final c'est
le patient c'est son matériel génétique
donc par la génomique
bien sûr il faut considérer que toutes
ces informations la semiga données sont
créés en charge par les ordinateurs
quorum lors de la présentation pour
finalement donner une précision clinique
pour le médecin pour que la décision
soit le plus adapté possible à de la
tension du patient dans cette maison
d'arrou définition vise à détecter les
processus dame native plutôt de conduite
et d'intervention bri il examine ajusté
c'est ce qu'on aime l'art du betis est
futuriste je suis à peu près à certains
que le mes enfants et les enfants des
enfants vont pouvoir accéder à ce genre
d' approche dans le futur d'un gamin de
rentrée du sujet lundi sur appel ces
parcours de dj mais j'aimerais quand
même qu'on parlait de foot l'adn la cdc
monique l'écart c'est la molécule de
l'est vu la diète en fait se retrouve
dans l'eau c'est le noyau sous forme
représente une forme de chromosomes a
fait l'adn c'est une molécule à
d'oublier ce site une série de lettres à
cgt c'est le livre d'eli en 2003 ne sais
pas si j mm
après 13,1 défendre pour se lancer avec
des formations internes il est et on
sait que ce grand lyon a fait un club
pour déjà news headlines une séquence de
lettres à cgt et c'est justement accordé
pour des protéines et des protéines se
sont ils
ce sont les structures fonctionnelles de
la cellule sont incarnés par cellex c
protège un quidam euros là c'est le
moussu est un organisme non plus
imaginer qu sione problème ou de jeunes
il vaudrait mieux les protéger au niveau
de l'organisme a été on sait maintenant
que les graines sont un reflet de la
cellule et de l'organisme si
effectivement leurs manteaux ou quelle
qualité de vie affecte vosges a
notamment affecté vous celle où est né
votre smartphone vous concerne que j'ai
comme ce niveau portrait des jeunes mais
vous voterez d'une cellule donc les
raisons pour ces raisons là depuis
plusieurs années dans la recherche
fondamentale s'est intéressée à
séquencer le génome humain
c'est ce qui a été fait en 2003 comme je
le disais les jets n'ont pas fait un
seul actif hélène sur le gène du
chromosome d'électronique rozon c'est
gênant d'intelligence et de 3.3
milliards de paires de bases d'élèves
pacifique se suivent ainsi libanais 4000
livre de 250 pages dont kim se mettre à
lire ce soir c'est l'issue de ce travail
donc c'est une présomption de
chromosomes et on sait maintenant que
dans l'être humain au club pour cent
mille jeunes seulement 20 les jeunes u15
est allé ces jeunes à surfer regarder le
même complexe ugu génétique
donc il ya plusieurs choses expression
des gènes beaucoup plus de jeunes
innocents qui sont incomplets donc j'ai
au québec représente ding seygouade les
génomes forme de livre des gens est un
grand livre les chromosomes présenterait
des châtaignes de ce livre ne règne des
français-libres notre adn
une lettre qui forment des maudits
phrases et les mutations d'adhésion
les airs actipôle affaibli la
ressemblance est intéressant donc ce que
pour nous n'a pas la médecine la haute
définition en utilisant le matériel
génétique c'est d'évaluer la santé d'un
patient est ingénieur sur la passion
donc afin d'évaluer et d'agir sur le
patient en se servant du matin jean si
on doit accéder à l'information
on doit accéder au grade de la vie on
doit comprendre ce grand é de lévis en
regardant d'orthographe et on doit tenir
et ont même l'algérie sur sur le terrain
de la vie en corrigeant les erreurs 10
pour rien fait qui commet lieu au niveau
du bijou de la cheville
michel de détente n'est tenu donc
pourquoi en fait ils venaient à santé
humaine à partir et ont pu même
l'annexion du jeune homme
alors c'est un matériel génétique
relativement stable permet une
évaluation personnalisée d'antin en fait
si jean et il devance 9 finance news
c'est ce qu'on pourrait imaginer voir
limitation s'installer d'un afin qu'on
développe la maladie
enfin construit ou 9 % c'est le brésil
la mairie naudin faire face à la
situation
cette période ci de l'allocation
d'éducation transmission obligeant les
install je sais mais ça pourrait lui le
rate aussi de défis comment vous allez
la génération 8 km le métabolisme des
médicaments dont souffrait d'allergies
saisonnières
sur des logiciels erp est ce qu'on
répond tout de la même façon au mythique
a maintenant et ça c'est entre autres
écrit dans mon job c'est intéressant un
jour d'avancé des fondations non de
façon plus précise
on pourrait identifier sur identifié des
mutations spontanées retrouver au sec
les malades afin d'avoir un traitement
ciblé pour les concerts tout temps qu'en
fait ce que je devais faire un avec la
médecine à eau à haute définition
c'est de trouver une signature génétique
qui est propre à vous pas votre voisin
pour une population exemple que je peux
donner du rhône de l'utilisation
d'informations génétiques d'un
traitement de certaines maladies
alors voici une liste de médicaments
qu'on va donner la chine rites et
religieux dans les détails à quelqu'un
qui est guidé investi quelque 1,5 au
mérite alors quand ça qui m'a frappé une
personne sur cinq au canada grâce à qui
grave donc
à l'heure actuelle ce forfait avec ses
jambes le diagnostic
malheureusement voici lynx ou de cancers
colorectaux et à ce moment là majorité
ces gens là bien qu'ils ont des parents
jean et ses différentes limitations
différents voici neuf patients avec les
patients en rouge dans l'imitation ex
ange notation grecque est en mutation
serbe mais ont tous des garçons
colorectaux avec trois mutations
différentes
ces passerelles avec soin dans toutes la
même thérapie seulement avec 30% démence
il serait intéressant volontat mois en
situation respect ces patients nation
fifa sont un visuel en séquences
l'actuel on va chercher des informations
sur leurs tueurs
et c'est passionnant sont bénins
stratifié selon la mutation est à la
médiation il est associé à un traitement
sont associés des traitements qui
permettent vraiment sûr encore de
répondre de façon optimale
al'approche vous a projeté la musique
donc et été essayé de la légalité ont
commencé et lui ai alors voici de voir
ça pourrait se faire dans le futur
un patient souffre d'une tumeur enfin
près d'alençon morale rapidement
d'échantillons daniel est prélevé à
partir de cet échantillon du moral c'est
analyser avec le bio informatique de
l'intelligence artificielle reviendra
quelques instants suivant la liste en
analyse cette ce génome les d'un médecin
spécialiste rencontre est possible et
donc ils sont capables de prendre une
décision sur la thérapie ciblée face à
haut profil
imaginez qu'on retrouve un sou profit
des mutations canton au sein de duke en
salle de ce patient et pas d'un autre
patient et à ce que je peux vous dire
que ça va non seulement permettre
des thérapies personnalisées ciblées
mais bien d'un coup certains médicaments
imagine quand ça qui évoluent et les
limitations d'une molécule d'une prime
fixe et que cette bottine la baule un
style qui relève monique une pour le
signer cette protéine la méthode
utilisée pour traiter une maladie
neurodégénérative peut même moment d'une
situation peut-être qu'en simple
développer un besoin d'avoir sept points
de cette patinoire active qui dans
l'appliquer 2010 neurogénératives mais
qui est maintenant évident car ça doit
vraiment repositionner au mythique exile
on main du rating la repousse chaînes
courtes séquences et donc sa famille
jusqu'à l'obtention de gestion en fait
d'un verbe d'un positionnement métier
rare pour les cancers pédiatriques donc
on y arrive
grâce à l'information génétique localité
est venue la santé humaine
allez jean on s'étire au maximum des
formations au niveau des milliards de
molécules l'adn donc ici aussi quatre
personnes qui ont 15 chez nos différents
et pour la même palette sept personnages
ou bien et qu'on devine scan
cette personne a besoin seulement de la
moitié de la dose vous répondre cette
personne a besoin deux fois plus de
médicaments pour répondre et c'est un
seul a besoin de tata nano mx 1 essai
sorte de besoin d'amour c'est ça qui est
dingue mais dans le futur avec l'abbé
cette année donc afin d'évaluer le
modèle génétique ou la tribune basquet
on doit accéder à l'information
génétique non on est de la technologie
de séquençage qui le jour de plusieurs
années mais qui évolue espérances
quinze habitants accéder ou textes du
grand livre de la vie je vous rappelle
jérôme est conçu de 3.3 milliards de
paires de base c'est du travail lire
tout ça et là dans mon exemple j'ai pris
mais j'ai commencé le programme gemini
qui commence est capable et s était
menée en 2003 ça depuis 13 ans de
travail et 3 milliards deux derniers
jours devant nous dix sept tasses verres
de vin qui nous faisait 15 3 milliards
de l'armée 13 ans très très loin
estimant bien sûr que l'on dort ce qui
est intéressant sur m6 les formations
entourage vous et en soutenant qu'en
2001 cinq ans et germain coutelle 100
millions
prenez plusieurs semaines et voyez-vous
coeur d'un tranquillement les cours ont
diminué près d'accord de table mais a vu
les sept la vie d'une nouvelle
technologie séquençage de lecture à
théding conduit par certaines compagnies
à faire de même a fait diminuer le
séquençage y est à tel point
qu'aujourd'hui en 2017
en plus c'est quand ses genoux mais en
2011 le train et pour me darwin trois
mineurs et pas seulement d'un compagnie
qui est responsable de tous ces
développements du mineur qui est temps
que d'ici quelques années capable de
séquencer le génome pour 100 dollars 70
et ils vont y arriver
donc on va avoir des formations bien en
connaît qui n'a que vous parlez de
millions d'années de détails on va
d'abord décrit dans pour comprendre
toute cette information donnée de ce
club on doit avoir des technologies
d'analysé de mégane à l'immunité
les bobines évidence artificielle la
passage profond des formations
politiques d'ong pour comprendre le
texte des promenades de l'être
comportons du monde jessica deux
chiffres pour les guides l'informatique
inchangé un humain première le percement
du muguet de downing n'a jamais tant
répertoire gino de tous les cas les
canadiens constant facilement à dix
années de suite
exapaq contacter si l'on s'écarte
seconde à tous les deux ans par exemple
pour le suivi de l'actualité
on passait du celtic on est dans la
démesure du dictateur paradait léger à
un texte simple un facteur sur une page
a4
cela donnerait une personne d'une bonne
à nyala soit 9.5 millions de kilomètres
c'est du matériel donc on devrait avoir
des orateurs et à la casse et de jerry
sénégal de nindja titanyen évolutif
d'aligner donner la chance à montréal si
ça tombe du poil la présentation la
présentation aux collègues
on n'a pas mis les meilleurs chercheurs
sur la planète l actuel à montréal pour
le développement des sciences des venets
et la belgique est déjà satisfait
davantage profond les subtilisation qui
existe c'est hors hermes
il va donner et c'était celui-là est
tellement important que les vues les
géants comme facebook choisi au real
pour les laboratoires ont déjà senti
ciel donc montréal sont plates formes
incroyables traité sénégal d'année et ce
sont des exemples anna qui vont évoluer
at il dit
les américains positifs donc à la
malicieuse et l'adn pour injure donc
c'est bien beau de camphin d'accès des
contraintes même stratégie mais peut-on
en génie donc je peux pas passer à côté
de l'édition gnc et sur des choses que
d'un match par les pandas grâce aux
recherches on n'a pas d'actions façe
d'activité depuis que gérant plusieurs
avaient compris que mc la bactérie
tueuse des temples de ta sortie n'est
adapté face à des écoutes et des
bactéries à franges et grâce à cette
compréhension fondamentale la défense
bactérienne adaptative ont développé que
la victime ou à l'inconnu système
d'édition et éthiques
c'est un plus pour quatre ans et nous
sommes j'en rêve dans les détails
imaginez que c'est un modèle à nice et
de ciseaux moléculaires support qui vont
peut être atteint avant la crise soit
1,3 milliard sur les 85 des cas très mal
les premières les 3000 ya trois femmes
et trois points comme étant le père de
ben arous nous voulons ce ciseau abidal
peut venir se soucier de façon
spécifique dans doit venir le coupé pour
lister soit arrivé j'ai notifié je
combine jeu la marque édité le général
en pis donc on parle pas de science
fiction avec une solennité conducteur du
le premier essai clinique
et fait un chêne sur la place 34
centimes en emmental industriels ou 2007
on part de virgin cet immense marché des
embryons l'exemple je voudrais ici qui
est peut-être la science fiction mais tu
peux être applicable dans son futur
d'approché belge des dégâts qui en est
une société vieillissante et 15 soldats
et générative de miles and johnson
on a identifié imaginons qu'on a
identifié des gènes imposable de la
maladie on avait déjà une bonne idée
mais il reste à faire ce travail
on peut mais on a les outils à partir de
ces patients isolés ni thomas ont fait
jusqu'ici un petit patch ici ça me fera
mal comment culture et grâce à
l'utilisation de quatre jeunes pour koné
à partager nos rues mais depuis quand le
séquençage est long on est capable de
différencier fibroblastes cellules
souches qui peuvent se différencier à
placer les solutions sont les seuls qui
peuvent se différencier par tout type de
cellules imaginer que ces cellules
souches comme hénin on connaît la
responsable la maladie en le 16 la
proche des sceaux ronnie lane en modifie
les jeunes sont responsables de malaise
français celui-là sont rendus main en
scène on les met dans un milieu masculin
à prier pour les différencie à niveau
c'est une rentrée agitée sur une
patiente et on pourrait l'imaginer
traités à matignon est négatif
khassawneh lynch est sûr at-il donc
enfin de confusion la nuit de nouvelles
disciplines médicinales comme avec senna
haute définition d'un courage et même
essentiel pour faire face aux défis
présents et futurs
la réussite et la mise en place de cette
nouvelle discipline devront se faire de
façon réfléchie une vitesse raisonnable
et respectent les fondements de nos
sociétés à juste titre heures
l'américaine dans son projet
cet été c'est le kin spot 65 millions
sur quatre ans qui vise à baliser
développement utilisation des
technologies d'émissions j-music cepos
par l'ex n 1 aux définitions possibles
des faux espoirs sont pas toutes les
vitesses enregistrées ou les 1 pour
graphique du génome qui peuvent être
présentement six départs l'équipe sky
one liturgie vous pouvez nous aider
initialement c'est peut être ça mais ce
coup-ci d'études scène pour l'état m
peut-être l'occasion à parler
mikati alors essayez de votation